[Music]
hey everybody
yeah what the hell is it monday he's
having another bad hair day
not a bad hair day
is every day a bad hair day now i went
hiking
i had my rucksack on and i was looking
going up hiking got all sweaty and [ __ ]
yeah yeah do you smell bad should i
smell it yeah i don't know i don't think
it's so i don't think so i changed my
shirt
oh okay i don't think for sure it washed
up a little bit other day
the other day when you just you seemed
like you came in here right after hiking
and i could smell you from like way over
here
i was like holy crap i'm still sweating
out those sars fry
[Laughter]
but i didn't smell smell like plastic
yeah he did kind of
it's like a weird chemical in his mouth
yeah we started a couple minutes late
because we were had to give beijing her
but uh yeah she just she really did not
want to have it
this movie was pretty interesting i
liked it um i liked this a lot and i
really want to thank everybody that
uh recommended it i probably would have
got around to seeing it you know anyway
because like a lot of uh
channels that i watch you know they
picked it as one of their best ones of
the year
i really dug this movie a lot i thought
it was like really really cool
good to show you how how much you can do
with a very small budget as long as you
you do a good job on it it's a period
piece it's happening in the 50s
it's got some really good characters and
from the 50s uh
you you really buy it that you're in the
50s uh
and one of them is a um he's like a
local radio
host yeah and um the other one is like a
high school girl who's a switchboard
operator
and uh what was her name faye fay yeah
she's cute as a bug
yeah she's played by sierra mccormick
who i guess she's on
that show supernatural that's where most
people probably know her from
you really buy it you know what i mean
that they're real people the only thing
that was a little odd about it is that
they had vaguely southern accents and
they're in new mexico they don't think
there were any southern accents although
they shot it in texas so yeah maybe
that's why i'm not really sure yeah
maybe
but um girls just reminds me
i really bought the characters you know
what i mean you got a guy who's
probably in his mid-20s acting like a
big shot because he's a local radio guy
he goes down to the high school and
[ __ ] meets faye for some kind of
thing he was televising her assuming not
television but
broadcasting a big event they were happy
yeah the basketball game
at the high school she's a switchboard
operator so she's got to work with her
so she could patch in [ __ ]
and uh you could you you could really
tell you know i remember that kind of
age difference
that she's really [ __ ] shining on
this guy she [ __ ] loves him because
she just won't shut the [ __ ] up
constantly i loved her character
i loved her so much yeah i used to run
into that in my 20s
keep [ __ ] talking they talk until you
like them
and then like you know you hours into it
we made a connection didn't we
yeah we're friends now that's that kind
of [ __ ] it's just
funny you really buy the characters they
were really endearing the the interplay
between the two of them was just so so
good
yeah you know what i mean and um
okay so in this one
this guy stumbles on to a situation that
like art bell would like
where there's some kind of paranormal
[ __ ] going on with these strange sounds
and then he plays the strange sound on
on the radio and some people start
phoning in and says yeah i know that
sound and then
telling him these stories about well
this guy calls in
and he's telling what he did in the in
the army
and that they were made they made all
this big uh
they had him digging these facilities
and building these walls out of bricks
and
um then they moved something in there it
was bigger than an airplane
and so you know they're setting up like
a ufo story
and um well i don't know if i should
spoil any of it
but it's just man it's pretty good
i would say the only thing i can knock
this movie for
is that
it kind of started to bog down into too
much of a dialogue based movie
they were they just kept interviewing
people and interviewing people what it
seemed like
and it kind of started to slow the story
down i was like well let's get to this
let's let's find out what the [ __ ] this
is and it takes a while to get to the
reveal it does get to the reveal
it's pretty satisfying um i think what i
liked the most about this one i like
that i mean i kind of liked everything
about this the characters are great
i love like the whole aesthetic of it
yeah it reminded me very much because
like you said so much of it is
dialogue based because a lot of it's
based in communication and auditory kind
of stuff
yeah so it's almost kind of like
listening to an art bell show
or it gave me like a real twilight zone
kind of vibe and it has
that kind of aesthetic to it too because
it's almost like doing a weird meta
thing
where because at the beginning of it
they're like
kind of homing in on this like old 50s
tv
and it's got like a twilight zone type
of show but it's called paradox theater
and so part of it like when they do
transitions it's almost like you're
seeing it for a little while like on an
old 50s style black and white tv
and then it kind of like slowly fades
into like realist realism i guess
so the fact that it does that so this is
very much
i don't want to say that it's not visual
because it is and it has like some
really amazing
that's amazing long shots like long
takes and stuff which get into in a
minute take a shot
out of the damn radio out of the radio
um
station station and go up the street all
the way down the street down the hill
across some fields and into the school
in a single shot
and like and it's long yeah it's like
through all these neighborhoods and like
it goes into the gym
around the gym kind of around the
players like up in the bleachers
out the window down the window like on
it's like an amazing amazing shot
yeah it's so so good had some of it had
to be done on a dune buggy or something
not doing buggy but uh
maybe an electric cart it's hard to say
what it was yeah like a weird dog or i
don't know if it was just a guy like
kind of well some of it had to be
something's moving too fast was moving
too fast unless they sped up parts of it
i'm not really sure but it was it was
like a really really cool like long take
of a shot
but like i said this is it's a very
auditory
movie there are like a lot of really
cool like long visual shots
but all in all it's this is a this is
definitely a movie that you really it
it's kind of like the enjoyment of it is
kind of from the auditory so it's like
listening to the people talking
listening to the weird
sounds like that the you know that the
thing in the sky is making
like that kind of like over the radio
and i just really really love like the
sound design
imagine if art bell
an art bell show was happening in the
1950s
and it was kind of like close encounters
of the third kind
yeah close encounters yeah that yeah i
was going to say that too it did give me
that kind of vibe as well
yeah so like i said don't expect it's
not like a super action-packed anything
it's not like that it's a very quiet
movie but
i found i don't know i just there's
something like really really cool about
it i just really liked the interplay
between the characters
you know it's like the way that one
great
scene of fey and she's just like sitting
at the
switchboard and there's like it's like a
10 minute scene of her just like
switching out different phones like
talking to different people trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] is going on
because people are calling in saying you
know there's something up in the sky
and all of a sudden it's like all like
interference and this weird noise and
then she's trying to like patch back to
the
radio station saying what's this noise
you know it keeps coming in over the
phone line and people keep
like she keeps losing connections and
[ __ ] like that so it's so there's like a
lot of build up of the stuff that's
going on and then like this
the guy calls billy and he kind of tells
his
big long story and then they end up
going to this old lady's house and she
tells this really creepy story about the
[ __ ] like that she knows some stuff
about it and it's just like a really
really cool it's hard to explain
the experience of it like i said it's
kind of like it's very twilight zoney
it's very art bell it's very that kind
of
like it the whole thing takes place over
a few hours in one night so it's all
night time
and um so i think that it really gives
it this weird like uncanny
kind of feeling to it like you're
sitting around it's kind of like back in
the 50s and you're sitting around in the
dark like listen to the radio it kind of
gives me that kind of vibe what i liked
about it was uh
uh the period felt correct even even
down to the uh
the mannerisms and the in
the dialects at the time you know what i
mean like um
it just it just sounded like 50s people
and they they acted like 50s people it
came across as very natural
right for for instance it showed how
competent
50s teenagers really were she's sitting
there [ __ ] jamming on that
switchboard
that that old-fashioned technology was
nonsensical i mean you know it was it
was
hard to learn everything took forever
[Laughter]
and uh dude was real young guy was real
professional on how he's gonna do a
broadcast and
so whoever wrote the script really knew
these jobs
he was talking about how to do a
broadcast in the [ __ ] show
and they just took it real seriously and
you remember
like stories of my fam like for instance
my granddad on my
father's side was a photographer and
still in that house were all these books
on
how to take a picture which like today
would just take a [ __ ] picture
but back then the lighting had to be
right you had to learn how to [ __ ]
select the type of film
because yeah it was a big deal lighting
and [ __ ] he was so he had a
he had a photo studio yeah and uh so he
did real portraits and everything
and evidently he was genius at that he
did a lot of things and he was also a
grocer you know they changed
they changed professions uh but when
they did they they really when it got
into it
and uh just show you kind of how
even though even though she's a kid
she's kind of adult in a way
a lot of adults yeah she says she's 16
at one point right yeah she's a high
school student and i think i think he
might be a high school student too or
maybe just out of high school yeah and
to put this in proper perspective you
know this is a couple years
outside of world war ii
when you see those b-17s and those b-24s
just
bombing the [ __ ] out of [ __ ] europe
out of germany
most of those guys flying those planes
are 19. yeah that's [ __ ] weird
they're the same age
as the guy 19 years old [ __ ]
dropping [ __ ] fire on people's
children they were a hardcore generation
you know yeah and you know you had 17
year olds in the ball turrets and crap
and when the landing gear [ __ ] broke
couldn't get the guy the ball turned
just landed on the ball turn and killed
the guy that happened several times
they were just they grew up fast
kind of neat in a way oracle said i
and i actually this only just now
occurred to me um
said did y'all talk about why the radio
station has the call sign
w-o-t-w war of the worlds yeah yeah
duh that only just occurred to me oh my
god it was like i was looking at it and
i was like i guess it kind of registered
but not really
and i was just kind of like oh yeah okay
that's pretty awesome yeah but it's like
so okay so i want to get a little bit
into this because one i have to say
when we were saying about like how
everything was a big pain in the ass
back then
i love the scene where him and faye are
going through
those um recordings that they got from
the library that they stole from the
library
to listen to it and he had yeah and like
do him doing the reel to reel and he had
to like hook up every single realtor and
then they'd listen to it for a few
seconds no that's not the one they were
looking for then he did it like again
and all this other kind of stuff
and i really liked it was so deliberate
and i really really liked that
um i will say the switchboard that they
used for that
was an actual still working switchboard
they got
one from the era that was still working
yeah the headphones and everything and
uh and so they got it to work
and so the thing about this the dude
that wrote and directed this andrew
patterson this is
amazingly his first movie he had the
idea
for this movie he said 10 years ago he
said this first idea for it he just
wrote a little note that said something
like
1950s ufo landing new mexico
um they wanted to base it loosely on
like kecksburg
um the foss lake disappearances you know
people saw light in the sky this guy and
then they disappeared
so they wanted to do it something like
that but not exactly based on that
and they wanted to make it so that it
they were trying to convey like what it
really would have been like
if you were alive in the 50s and this
[ __ ] happened in your town and what that
would have been like
and i think they were really really good
at conveying that now the thing about
this too is that the writer director
like i said he had the idea for this ten
years ago he's
he started working on like commercials
and [ __ ] like that for like some sports
team in texas i think
and he raised he saved seven hundred
thousand dollars and he paid for this
movie
himself yeah he saved up seven hundred
thousand dollars and made this movie
they definitely did a good job i mean
like i said they even studied the
mannerisms of the 50s like faye you know
just
when she moved yeah the way she moved
the way she
was straight out of 50s television yeah
i totally bought it she had her hair
pulled back she was a little short thing
you know
hair pulled back totally round head with
these damn
the cat eye glasses cute cat eyes
glasses that wouldn't work on anybody uh
older than [ __ ]
anybody older than 20 would look like an
old lady with them but you know i mean
at least for our generation but and just
the way she moved and she's flying
around that damn switchboard and
everything
and those damn bobby socks and [ __ ]
skirt and she was so cute like how
enthusiastic she was
yeah and then you know she wasn't really
comfortable in cars she would just run
down the road instead of getting into
somebody's car
because she said she kept forgetting
this that she like could ride in a car
just all kinds of what made the movie
really was just a dialogue and all the
personality quirks
of these very believable new mexico out
in the middle nowhere 50s [ __ ] people
yeah i think that really like i said the
character work was so good and
it really gave you this creepy sense of
like listening to somebody
yeah telling you a creepy story one of
the callers that called in you know he's
talking and he's talking about his time
in the army and building that thing and
i was listening to his voice and
everything and i said to jenny says he's
black
yeah and and then it comes out later on
the conversation he comes out that was
kind of like a significant
point yeah and they're like what he's
like that's why nobody listens to what
i'm trying to tell yeah
he was involved in a damn special
operation and the whole crew was black
guys because they were mexicans
and he said there were a few yeah he
said and he said that
they were all assembled because they
were working on his top secret thing
and nobody would believe them if they
[ __ ] said anything about it
yeah which that's true they did that
kind of [ __ ]
yeah the manhattan project okay where
they were making the atomic bomb
all your janitors were black and they
all made sure
that they were totally illiterate that
way they couldn't read anything they
couldn't be in a spy
they couldn't conduct any espionage for
foreign powers
and they wouldn't wouldn't understand
what an atomic bomb was or how to make
one
yeah they're just kind of like i just
got a job cleaning [ __ ] up i'm not
worried about anything other than that
they couldn't really couldn't read
anything on the
chalkboards or you know and they
couldn't steal files because it couldn't
read anything
so yeah they did that kind of stuff yeah
so when that [ __ ] came out the story
of course i got more engrossed in it
yeah you know
because it does sound kind of believable
well that's what i mean this sounded
very
plausible it sounds plausible and then
you have 1950s explanations
of [ __ ] what what aliens would be
doing
which is a trip you just like i said
it's a period piece
yeah it's just they really really
captured the moment and like i said i
loved the whole
the tv like the black and white like
fading it i loved that
and can i say it's like i guess this is
not too much of a spoiler but can i say
i think my favorite scene in this
other than that really long shot it's
like there were so many good scenes in
this
but i think my favorite scene was when
they were in the car
with that couple and they were going out
to like where people had
seen this thing in the sky like out by
the side by the edge of town or whatever
and they decided to start they played
back that thing that that old lady had
said like that weird thing that sounded
like another language
and like the couple in the front seat of
the car like there are
like their heads just went back like
that oh it was up like
my guy goosebumps like when i saw that
it was like so so creepy
but it's just like it's not like i said
it's not a horror movie exactly but it's
kind of
i mean it's a sci-fi drama i guess i
would call it
yeah you know what i'm saying um but
it's not you know it's not aliens like
pew pew it's something like that it's
just it's a
character twilight zoney kind of
vibe to it and i thought it was like
really cool another thing that i saw on
wikipedia that i thought was very funny
they said so they wanted this to be new
mexico so they could reference
you know some of the other bases around
there and some of the other like ufo
lore
but they said they scouted around a
really long time for a town to use
which they eventually found it was in
texas they said because they wanted
the gymnasium to look absolutely perfect
but they said that
they had to get rid of they had to spend
twenty thousand dollars to get rid of
uh what is it the three-point line like
on the basketball field because i guess
they didn't have that back in the 50s
that's like a new
rule so they had to like spend all this
money again i'm like holy crap it's like
probably
no i wouldn't have even thought of that
because i don't know [ __ ] about
basketball i guess
but um clearly because i probably said
it wrong but i just thought that was
really funny that somebody actually
thought of that
i was like yeah we need to get rid of
that because some [ __ ] somewhere is
gonna like notice like hey they didn't
have that in the 50s
i think this is supposed to be well he
references
sputnik at one point which that was
1957.
he did that [ __ ] before sputnik yeah
that's what i'm saying so this must have
yeah but like the um
everett asked him about sputnik and then
so sputnik must have already happened so
this must be afternoon
that guy never just say what his name
was did he he just said billy
billy that's right yeah but that was a
pseudonym probably yeah addressed tila
yeah we liked it i yeah i loved it i
thought it was great yeah i thought it
was great yeah
yeah it was a good movie i liked it yeah
um like i said it was
it's one of those kind of movies that
shows you how good of a movie you can
make on a very limited budget
you know what i mean if you if you if
you know if you've got good actors you
got a good script
and you got people that give a [ __ ]
about the production this [ __ ] comes off
real good and really the
it was kind of like watching an art veil
program for me art bill mixed with uh
close encounters of the third kind
yeah this definitely this definitely you
could you could tell that
the writer director the uh andrew
patterson that made this you could tell
this was a labor of love
yeah he put up 700 000 of his own money
he had this idea 10 years ago
and he has been like trying to make it
since then
all the characters very believable um
very believable very kind of like
lovable characters you know
yeah she's the [ __ ] best i loved her
so much
chick [ __ ] flying around on the damn
switchboard
you know running through the woods in
her little saddle shoes carrying that
baby
yeah and then like we got the guy from
the what was the guy from the radio
station's
name everett everett yeah and everett
who's like a 20-something
local big shot because he's talking yeah
because he runs the radio station yeah
you're real professional about
everything you know just
and i said it was very true very true to
50s
culture you know how people
became very proficient with this really
[ __ ] old-fashioned technology it
became very proficient
they had a lot of self-respect and they
grew up kind of quick
in a way you know just a few years
before like i said
in world war ii you had 19 year olds
[ __ ] flying b-17 bombers [ __ ]
burning up [ __ ]
burning up [ __ ] dresden you know so
people grew up different back then
and you see it in the movie it's good i
love
too that when they release this because
it's actually i think it premiered at uh
the slam dance film festival like the
beginning of
2019 but amazon didn't pick it up until
spring of this year and so they released
it to vod and then they also released it
to drive-ins
because this would be a really good
thing to see in a drive-in like
through your own radio and [ __ ] like
that just because it's so 50s and it
would just be like the perfect
you know that like might be medium you
know what i mean it's just like it'd be
really cool i
i kind of wish that i had seen this in
the drive-in actually yeah i guess t saw
because she's talking about she had a
huge crush yeah
i i got into that earlier you know what
i mean
when you're in your 20s and you had
these little high school girls they
[ __ ] get
get a big huge crush on you that
happened to me
you knew that you knew that it was going
on because they just won't shut the [ __ ]
up they're just going to talk to you
they could talk you they're going to
talk you into liking them
you know you like you don't you you know
but they're funny yeah and all the stuff
they were talking about
she was talking all about like the this
she was talking about like self-driving
cars
all this stuff that she had read in the
magazine about like what was gonna
happen
in the future like all this stuff they
were gonna put in the road so the cars
could drive themselves and all this yeah
and i like the fact the guy that called
it the guy that called in
uh the black guy he doesn't he doesn't
obviously
he's not of course not speaking in
ebonics it's 1950s
you know i mean it's not real obvious
what race he is
but i called it i said just by just by
what the
what the mission he was talking about
and his reservations about things and i
went how much of
his black and jenny was like he might be
and then later on he comes back he says
you see i'm black
yeah that's not a big deal is it like no
no not at all i could not because they
they wouldn't have been believed that
yeah which i thought that was a [ __ ]
great touch
because that's that's that's accurate
that's the kind of [ __ ] they did it
really was yeah
and i manhattan project yeah so like i
said i can see why so many people like
picked this as one of their favorite
movies of the year i mean i can easily
see that yeah
like like i said some of the shots are
amazing just the whole tone of it is
amazing the sound design
is amazing i loved the sound design on
this character work amazing it's just
like super super fun
i actually wouldn't mind owning this one
or you know watching it again or
whatever
it's good uh so yeah we uh we're done
oh yeah uh t also said we should do a
ufo things i love the ufo shows
i'll have to put that up and back and up
in the uh rotation because we already
had the vote for
this week i wanted to talk about the
phoenix lights
uh i'm to get we got i'm going to talk
about the phoenix lights i want to write
that down
talking about tic tac ufo really is
is kind of a waste of time because the
pilot is out there [ __ ] talking about
it you can't out talk the [ __ ] actual
witness
but there's so many witnesses to to the
phoenix lights i'm talking about the
real phoenix lights not the flares
yeah even though some of that [ __ ] might
be flares
it's hard to tell and i've seen a lot of
flares dropped out of aircraft and
launched out of artillery pieces and
mortars and stuff and i was in the army
it doesn't
really look like flares usually with a
flare you can see trail of smoke above
it
and they don't [ __ ] stay up in the
air for all that long
um they tend to drift apart too that was
a weird formation of lights
but that's not the real one that there
there is a real video of the of the
craft and it's real staticky at night
because it because it's a low light and
they're using a vh
vhs camera that's not made for low light
so it looks like a bunch of static
and you can see like five lights in a
sharp
v at a distance they kind of zoom in on
it
and it's and they're talking about it
the people who are seeing it at the time
like look at that thing
that's that's the only real bona fide
video of the event
according to the witnesses that saw it
so yeah that's it
um symington the governor came out
said he saw it which uh
some people who did see it said the
simon is full of [ __ ] that he lied that
he saw it but i don't know i don't think
he did live
he saw it i think he did see it oracle's
song about the marfa lights
the what lights martha i don't remember
that m-a-r-f-a
she says my husband and i went out to
martha a few years back and saw them
ourselves
yeah oh those are those things out in
the desert right
yeah i think yeah yeah yeah i think i
know yeah
yeah they're out there i think it might
have something to do with the
monkey waves yeah light
refraction you know because there's i
think there might be uh
freeways out there in the distance and
sometimes when the weather
when the weather conditions are right it
might kind of like bend the light like
through monkey waves i don't know i
heard a couple of good explanations but
you know there's no telling you can't go
up on them it's like a mirage
they go away yeah so it needs me to
believe that
it's something real far away
you know yeah but i'll definitely put um
i'll put like art bell ufo stuff i'll
put that in the poll for
yeah because like i said the the poll
for this coming saturday show is already
done so i already have the topic for
this show but i can put it in the
poll for the following week and we'll
see if everybody votes for that one so
if you want that go and vote
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah so uh
you you don't no they're just talking
okay
all right but yeah so if you really like
sci-fi kind of especially like indie
sci-fi like quieter sci-fi
um and you like 1950s stuff twilight
zone type stuff
then you definitely need to see the vast
of night it's on amazon prime i don't
think it's streaming anywhere else
that's where we watched it so uh yeah
check it out i thought it was really
great
you ready you ready you're done yeah i'm
just listening they're in there talking
good they're talking they're
having a good conversation so you can't
talk about ufos without talking about
our bill
man i could do a whole show on art bill
well i have i have that
in the topic like a heartfelt like an
art bell tribute
show talking about where he came from
and what happened
you know and his wife and about there in
the nevada i miss art bell
yeah uh they had a youtube channel for a
while that was playing all the art bell
reruns from the past and their every bit
is listening every bit of fun to listen
to now as they were back then even
though you knew that
that [ __ ] was 99 [ __ ] well you're
just listening to stories it's like i
like listening to scary stories art
could take the dumbest i don't care if
it's real or not
art could take the dumbest [ __ ] that he
didn't believe in and make that [ __ ]
sound [ __ ]
dramatic as hell and today on our belly
you know coast to coast you know and
then you go like
tonight we're going to talk about baby
sass
we know about the adult sasquatch but
today we're going to talk about the baby
sass
get your lsd ready
[Laughter]
all right today we're going to talk to
some [ __ ] that says he built an
elevator to mars you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's do it
we're going to talk about we're going to
talk about the north florida
and bottomless pit endless hole to hell
mark whitaker here with us today says he
has dug a hole
to hell and has met the devil himself
eating bringing back samples brimstone
yeah imagine that [ __ ] that's like
something that would be on there
yeah that too yeah i could totally just
get out of like [ __ ] the night
gallery
he's looking down in his basement
[ __ ] digging a hole
trying to talk to the devil
[Laughter]
by my company by my calculations i
should be there in six months
exactly all right so anyway
uh we'll be back tomorrow as usual talk
about another movie i don't know which
one it's gonna be yet but i'm gonna find
one later and
we'll talk about it tomorrow so uh
thanks everybody for stopping by
and we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow bye